when i was 20 years old i finally get
the diagnosis
of degenerative bone disease
degenerative disc disease so my spine
was deteriorating and this was the
reason why my hip broke and the reason
why my body was breaking down and i went
in to see my physician and i'm just
being you know a young optimistic kid i
was like okay so what do we do to fix it
let's go he was like
i'm sorry son this is incurable but i
asked him do this does this have
anything to do with what i'm eating and
he put his hand on my shoulder and he
said what you're eating has nothing to
do with this this is something that just
happens and i'm sorry that it happened
to you so he told me that this had
nothing to do with what i was putting in
my mouth but then he wrote me a
prescription to put some pills in my
mouth
i know sibo effect
is when someone gets an a negative
injunction from an authority figure
that something bad is going to happen
you it bypasses your logic
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
today on the pretty intense podcast i
have sean stevenson he's the author of
the usa today national bestseller eat
smarter and the international best
seller sleep smarter he's a best-selling
health writer as well as has the number
one health podcast called the model
health show we talked so much about his
own health journey i always think it's
so important for people to understand
where someone's knowledge and experience
and advice comes from and sean has such
a story he was given an incurable
diagnosis just after college it was a
bone disease and he you know shares just
about how he pulled himself out of that
hole and has healed himself from an
incurable disease and so
i thought that that was just such a
fascinating story so inspirational
um and then of course we got into some
of the more nitty gritty things about
what he's learned since then and you
know the power of our thoughts and how
that manifests into our genetic
expression as well as just the power of
particular foods and exercise and how
that just gives us a chance to live a
full life and avoid a horrible thing
that none of us want which is dis-ease
disease in the body you know there are
so many tools out there sean is an
insanely smart and educated person and
all of these aspects and it comes from a
place of experience and passion and he
just wants to share that with everybody
so please enjoy this amazingly inspiring
show with sean stevenson
i'm really excited to do this oh my gosh
as i've been deep diving i'm like
there's like
you know i knew that you knew a lot
about health and wellness but you know
there's really no territory we probably
couldn't get into that you don't have
knowledge and statistics and uh you know
some recommendation on it's it's really
amazing thank you that means a lot that
definitely means a lot and listen so i
just i've been diving into your world as
well and i just listened to your episode
with greg braden oh my god
that's like for sure
greg is like my everyday thoughts like
those the things that we talk about are
i love the universe i love quantum
physics i love reality
and um
i've always been into health and
wellness but when it comes to when it
comes to
all of that kind of stuff i'm like oh my
god do you think about that stuff too
of course you know when all of this
craziness start to kick off the first
two people that i look to like what is
their perspective was bruce lipton
and greg braden oh my god so yeah i know
bruce so fortunately like i was able to
have a conversation with him and feature
his perspective
and i mean my goodness it was just it
was very affirmative because i kind of
already knew
where they would take things and i mean
they were both just kind of um
really
trying to shift our focus back to
you know empowerment and being able to
take a meta perspective on all of these
things and bruce was really hammering
home he took the took us through really
the biology of fear and how that's
compromising our immune system and this
was over a year ago when i had him on
and talked about it and i don't know if
you saw this but i posted the cdc study
the most recent study and so they
analyzed it was 800 us hospitals over
540 000
uh covet patients and they found that
the number one risk factor for death
from covet is obesity which is something
we know are we doing something about it
of course not
but the second leading risk factor for
death from covet in this massive
meta-analysis
was anxiety and fear-related disorders
well then my questions that i have in
mind are going to be perfect i mean
bruce i've learned so much i mean i want
i would i would love an intro to bruce
we've been i've been trying to get him
on i've had greg and then the other part
of this like little trio is joe dispenza
like those guys end up going out and
doing speaking and speaking gigs and
stuff and so i've had joe on i've had
gregon and i really want to have bruce
because the epigenetics
epigenetics fascinates me and i have so
many questions about epigenetics and how
you know i was listening to him talk
about
splitting um having a i think it was a
what would it have been a gen a gene
that was multiplied into like 10 000 10
000 of them were multiplied into and
then they split them into three dishes
and each of those dishes were given
different environments and then all of
those genetics became the environment
and so
like this whole idea of epigenetics and
how we become who we are and if we
if epigenetics is something that we have
to be cognitively aware of for it to
become our become us or if we're able to
just be in proximity to it i mean i'm
just so so so fascinated by all that
he's a pro at that first of all i'll
connect you so that's already done
second of all the thing that he always
brings me back to
even when i talk about the environment
even when i talk about you know uh
various expressions and potential he
always leads me back to the fact that
your thoughts are the most powerful
influence over all of it
it is your thoughts that are determining
your genetic expression you know to the
nth degree so whether we believe in it
or not it's still creating yeah and yeah
so it's super fascinating yeah well
we're creating our reality i mean when
you
you know people have said for a long
time that
you know this is just kind of a stage
and we're actors and we you know we're
just
whether we're holographic in nature or
not but our thoughts are creating our
reality and i think wasn't it the double
slit experiment that showed that that
when you put attention on
to something it changes it which means
that our our our conscious awareness to
something is what's creating that's just
mind-blowing
it is but this is you know it's
put it under this big umbrella of the
observer effect
and you know there's even a really
fascinating study i first learned about
it from greg braden
and it was the the phantom dna
experiment
and
and so the thing about me too is like
i'll take those things and i will just
like
go in deep and actually you know review
the analysis review the studies the
outcomes and start to look at start to
question things like what did they not
see in this what could be another
potential what's another explanation
but the phantom dna experiment um
basically they took a vacuum which
if you have a vacuum and i'm not talking
about a vacuum cleaner i'm talking about
like a chamber that eliminates
everything from being able to enter it
or to leave it
and there's no like you know oxygen
infusion none of that stuff is just a
it's a it's a closed vacuum seal
and there would be nothing in the vacuum
they made sure that there was nothing at
all in the vacuum
but there's something you cannot
possibly remove which is biophotons
these kind of little packets of of of
energy of light that make up our reality
so there's nothing they can do about
that and so what they did was they took
some human dna and put it into the
vacuum
and something really strange happened
the biophotons that were just kind of in
the seemingly random assortment
throughout in the vacuum
conform themselves and basically attach
themselves to the human dna they left in
their scattered
arrangement and conformed to the dna
now that was already interesting and now
here's where it gets really weird
they took the dna out and expected the
biophotons to just go back to their
scattered seemingly random arrangement
but they didn't they still stayed in
conform and confirmation
with the human dna as if the dna was
still there
so for that moment
the human dna
left a permanent impression upon the
very stuff that makes up our reality
and so this speaks to again that's just
a tiny portion of our dna let alone this
conscious sentient being and how much
power we have on influencing the world
around us
so you know it's experiments like that
but then it just goes back also to
you know when i mention our thoughts
influencing our our genetic expression
every thought we have
creates correlating chemistry in our
bodies instantaneously
and this is the rub is that whether the
thought is real based on accurate data
or if it's based on something that's
totally made up
your brain and your physiology don't
know the difference but you are
instantaneously changing
your entire biochemistry every single
cell in your body the trillions of cells
are instantaneously changing based on
your thoughts every single micro second
i've been saying thoughts become things
for a long time and i finally i was
prepping for an interview i did with
rhonda brine do you remember the secret
of course yeah so
i watched a secret back in 2008 which is
still a couple just two years after it
came out so it's still pretty early and
i watched it before i interviewed her
recently and
in it i don't remember exactly which one
said it but it's like thoughts become
things and i was like oh my god that's
why i've been saying that for so long
because that's probably where i heard it
and you know you're just explaining how
that's true and so what i love is that
because you're such a you're such a deep
diver on the information and the and the
analytics of things and the science and
and the technical part of part aspect of
all of these things or thoughts that we
have or awarenesses that we have which
is so cool because there's so many
people that are willing to take things
at face value and then you know
that's fine um but it's when you can
truly explain it from a scientific
perspective from a biochemistry
perspective
that it really convinces and anchors
people into
a new level of
not just awareness but belief in that
awareness because belief is like the
magic sauce to everything it's one thing
to say you know i can go drunk a
basketball it's another thing for me to
actually go believe that i could go dunk
a basketball so
because i'm five foot one
um so that that believing is i think
what really will help people transform
which is why i'm excited about this
conversation because you know i feel
like in our world today there's so many
so much going on there's so much like
outside of our control
um to
directly go out and do something about
and so the only control we really have
is over ourselves
and you know in
the truth is is that the collective
holds the power and so so long as we
participate in a system participate in a
thought pattern or a paradigm it
continues to exist like i say you know
if you don't think that the newspapers
telling the truth stop buying it and
they won't exist very long you know if
you don't think that the news is telling
you the right thing on the television
stop watching it and i promise you it'll
go away and so what i want to have a
conversation about is not necessarily
out there but in here and what can we do
because
basically if we all changed our
and i'm going to hit some buckets with
you because you just i just i'm
fascinated i love the knowledge you have
but if we can affect our mind and our
body and our spirit and all the things
that have to do with us if we all did
that the world would be transformed um
and so the best thing that we can do is
is live an autonomous life and and be
sovereign in our being and learn how to
tap into our intuition and have uh be
able to be discerning about things and
ask questions with comfort instead of
hostility and
i think that this is a perfect
conversation to get people to look at
themselves and i know i'm rambling on
but i want you to talk a whole lot after
this about all these different buckets
and topics that i have for you but i
think that that's the most empowering
thing that we can do and so then just as
you said with uh with the mind and with
whether a thought is real or not we
start to create our reality and then
essentially we transcend into a
completely different reality than the
one that we've been in once we transform
our mind our body our spirit our
thoughts our patterns our routines and
then what's the difference then we you
know we can be in the world but be in a
different set different frame of mind
and our reality changes and then once
that changes for enough people then
essentially everything is transformed um
overall in the world so you know big
mission but it starts with the self so
i'm first
so
first off i'm i'm curious if you have a
story how you got into health because i
think i'm i'm just curious about that if
you have a story and then and then
getting into some of the more scientific
stuff sure yeah i had no idea that i'd
be doing this work today that i'm doing
um you know for me i grew up wanting to
be an athlete
and i went to one of those high schools
that turns out professional athletes uh
like ryan howard mvp
from the phillies shout out to my guy
ryan he was one of my linemen he was a
blocker i had no idea he could even play
baseball you know but david freeze other
folks like that so
um and when i was just 15 years old i
ran a uh four five forty
and if people who are aware of like nfl
combine all that stuff that's pretty
fast for a kid
and so i just had all these aspirations
and just the people around me like sean
like sean's got the juice
you know so not that kind of juice the
the the inherent juice or the sauce
you're in health and wellness i think
people trust you when you say juice what
you really mean hey there's a lot of
stuff people don't know about out there
that's true but so you know so that was
really my aspiration and just coming
from the environment that i come from i
really didn't have any examples of
people being successful doing anything
else other than that honestly you know i
grew up in an environment where you know
there's a lot of violence there's a lot
of drug use
you know
my my role models really were drug
dealers and people who were in gangs and
it just it is what it is because they
they seem to have some semblance of
success
and so and i was bussed out to quote the
good school you know i had that
opportunity to do that so i got
different exposure
and i also had teachers who took an
interest in me fortunately my my
grandmother always instilled in me this
really love for education and i think
that the love
it comes from a dynamic
experience of making bringing education
to life
right so making everything really fun
and engaging and so that's what i strive
to do today little did i know thanks to
my grandmother and my little first
garfield writing pad that she gave me
um
you know
being in this environment i remember i
had a teacher uh miss blackmore who
published one of the the i wrote a poem
and she published it in the school
newspaper and so it's just like she
affirmed that my i can create something
that brings value to other people
right i can my words i can create
something from my mind
and it can impact others like it just
like this light bulb came on
and so i had that continuous thread but
fate had other plans for me because i
was actually at track practice
uh running a 200 meter time trial which
is half the olympics just wrapped
recently so people probably know but
it's half the track and it was just a
time trial was me one other person my
coach
and as i was coming off the curve of the
track into the straightaway
i broke my hip
and yeah yeah and nobody touched me i
didn't fall there was no trauma and
you're like yeah i was 15 years old and
the iliac crest my the tip of my hip
just broke and i thought i didn't know
what happened at the time i i'd never
been hurt before and so i just came up
limping took a couple of days before i
went and got an x-ray done but there my
bone was just floating off in space
and you know the physician at the time
was like you know gonna get you some
insects some crutches stay off the leg
you know you're gonna come back better
than ever and you know it's true when
you're a kid like you can heal from a
lot of stuff pretty quickly but nobody
stopped to ask how did this kid break
his hip from running
root cause right right it should be a
foundational very
simple question to ask but what i was
exposed to then was something called
standard of care
all right
and so it's just like this big machine
like you know people come in they've got
these particular issues these are the
things you do
and a lot less investigation and inquiry
and analyzing like what are the
conditions within my body within my life
that might be creating the
susceptibility
right and so that was just one of a
string of injuries once i got the
football season that next year which was
supposed to be that was my big moment
you know i've still got game films i
actually still have dreams about like
playing football which is so weird for
me to say this i've never said this
before except to my wife um but
what happened was i came out great
season i scored like six touchdowns in
three games or four four games sorry
and everything was looking great but
then the injuries just one after the
other i ended up with half a dozen
different injuries i've got game films
where you can see me just
breaking away on a sweep and i'm i've
beat everybody the defensive back is
trying to catch up with me i'm five
yards from the end zone and i just i
just collapse
because i tear a muscle or whatever my
body was falling apart and it wasn't
until
when i was 20 years old i finally get
the diagnosis
of degenerative bone disease
degenerative disc disease so my spine
was deteriorating and this was the
reason why my hip broke and the reason
why my body was breaking down and now
i've got this diagnosis
which in one sense it was a little bit
it felt it felt encouraging because now
i know oh there's this thing happening
yeah at least you know why
but and you know just to make a long
story short this is also where things
took a spiral downward in order for
things to
skyrocket forward all right because
there's a good idea
it's
it's like on instagram the other thing
or it's like you got to pull a boat like
the the arrow back before it can go
forward so
it's it's like that so what was the low
well little did i know at the time
that's such a great analogy
that this was writing that story because
when i went in to see my physician
you know he took the mri he put it up
for me to see and he told me that i had
this condition
and i'm just being you know a young
optimistic kid i was like okay so what
do we do to fix it let's go
and he looked he literally just like
looked at me like i was from another
planet he was like i'm sorry son this is
incurable
and
i and to this day i have no idea why i
asked him this question
but i asked him do this does this have
anything to do with what i'm eating and
the way that i'm exercising
and to say that i don't have any idea i
have some seeds of it you know i had my
nutritional science class and you know
i've been an athlete
but i didn't really understand that
these things matter as much to ask this
physician when he's telling me there's
nothing i can do
and he put his hand on my shoulder and
he said
what your
these are his exact words
he said that
what you're eating has nothing to do
with this this is something that just
happens and i'm sorry that it happened
to you
so he told me that this had nothing to
do with what i was putting in my mouth
but then he wrote me a prescription to
put some pills in my mouth
right so this is the level of
thinking and also by the way just a
sidebar that i didn't use to talk about
but he was clearly not in a good state
of health himself
all right um but anyway so
at this point i get this diagnosis and
what was engaged and what we can talk
about of course i want to circle back
this is important to talk about was
something called the nocebo effect
all right and the placebo effect many
people have heard of which is you get a
positive injunction that you take this
particular placebo but you don't know
that it's a placebo
to lower your blood pressure and your
blood pressure proceeds to lower or your
blood sugar normalizes or your cancer
tumor starts to dissolve and we've got
documentation there's a i know some of
this stuff can sound a little bit
far-fetched
um there's wonderful books if you want
it in a more consolidated place like
mind over medicine by dr lisa rankin for
example but this is pretty easy to find
with a simple google search so
resolving symptoms that back pain john
sarno says in a john sarnos what's that
book called the
um something about back pain and
basically it being emotional
psychological
i think it might be the back pain cure i
know what you're talking about like that
yeah
so whether it's you know psychological
distress anxiety uh insomnia
uh cancer diabetes heart disease the
list goes on and on we see placebos are
so effective and on average they're
about 33 effective in clinical trials
somehow 80 effective and this is again
this is based on your perception that
this drug is doing this particular thing
that's how powerful our minds are
and
however on the other side a nocebo
effect
is when someone gets an a negative
injunction from an authority figure
that something bad is going to happen so
this is when you might hear from a
physician that you have
you know you have two weeks to live or
you'll never walk again
or this is incurable
and these are all things that you know
over the years in my clinical practice i
heard people coming in they had those
same stories and that was my story as
well
and if if you're getting this injunction
especially your there's parts of your
mind that are naturally skeptical but
when you believe that somebody has a
position of authority and they know
far more like a different universe of
information on it than you do you it
bypasses your logic
and so for me it bypassed my logical
mind because i've always been somebody
who's very optimistic and kind of uh
assertive
in getting things done and now i just
relented to believe what he said and so
i went from like a nuisance of a pain
that i was dealing with when i went in
to see him to chronic debilitating pain
within you know a matter of weeks and so
i was on a slew of medications
um you know celebrex was hot then um but
all of these different medications
medications to sleep because i couldn't
sleep because the pain was so bad
and every time i go to see somebody else
another physician to get another opinion
which i always recommend people to do i
leave with another prescription
and this is this is part of the the
problem and by the way if any if you
anybody listening if you ever do get
a diagnosis you know a bad bill of goods
oftentimes the this our system is
created in such a way that it's forcing
you into a decision you never want to
make
a permanent decision on a temporary
emotion
you know you usually have time to
reassess things to seek a different
opinion
a second or third opinion but here's the
key
you want to seek an opinion
from a physician or healthcare provider
that has the same goal as you not just
for me i was just going to see other
people on other people's recommendations
if your goal if you've been diagnosed
with diabetes and now you're you're
about to be on metformin or insulin and
your goal is to not have type 2 diabetes
you want to see a practitioner
who whose goal is the same as yours who
knows like this doesn't have to be your
story
you know so that's very important so
just a little sidebar and i'm going to
wrap this story up so
um i go through this is the you know the
dark night of the soul experience
two years of chronic debilitating pain
i make it i'm i'm so afraid of the pain
that i don't move very often like i
spend probably 90 percent of my day
lying on the floor sitting on my crappy
college apartment couch and thinking
about pain thinking about pain
constantly it was it was just ever
present in my awareness and now that i'm
even more inactive because each time i
see another physician they told me bed
rest be careful don't do anything
which
some most often 99.9 of time the worst
thing you can do is to do nothing if the
pain is acute sure you know take a
couple of days but
it's not just my bones are going to
atrophy now everything in my body's
going to atrophy if i'm not using my
body
if you don't use it you lose it
but
it's like a car it's like a house i mean
i have lots of houses i don't live in
and i'm like man the toilet doesn't work
and then there's a flood and the seal
broke and then this happened and then
that happened and it's like you know it
you do i mean it is it is a matter of
using things so that it stays fresh and
so it stays current and so it stays
strong
and so that you're aware when something
shifts as well because how do you know
how you feel
when you push something to the limit how
do you know if there's a problem if you
never test it
you know the body is an incredible
indicator of other things it's like you
know i there was something at some point
in time i read that talked about having
a good relationship with the signs that
your body's sending you and be glad that
it sends you the sign of
you know some kind of dis-ease in the
body
instead of you just dropping dead it's a
warning sign
very simple this is so
unfortunately the way that our
our healthcare system is constructed is
to take symptoms and to create a
diagnosis
and a label instead of understanding
that
every single person every single person
on this planet who has type 2 diabetes
doesn't have the same type 2 diabetes
it's just a category
of symptoms and you get this label
and the symptom
of
insulin resistance or leptin resistance
this is feedback from our bodies that
something is is off here it's like a
built-in alarm going off and instead of
addressing the alarm we silence it or we
suppress the symptom
but what happens inevitably is that the
alarm will go off in another way
right so it's just like oh you're not
paying attention to this world then i'm
going to give you all of this additional
body fat as a protection mechanism or a
warning which our body is always doing
things to try to protect us
and
or now because you're doing this now i'm
going to
have an impact on say which by the way
statins and anybody can go to dr google
and look this up now but i was sharing
this i don't know years and years ago
with statin use
we see about a 30 increased incidence of
developing diabetes right so we're
taking a drug to try to modulate
superficially modulate our cholesterol
and then we have this side effect this
rampant side effect of insulin
resistance and diabetes taking place
and it's again we're suppressing a
symptom and the body's manifesting
another alarm but what do we do we take
more drugs and drugs have their place
pharmaceutical medications have their
place just unfortunately we're in a
system that is drug first you know it's
pharmacological
training really you know we're not we're
taught very little
about
how to actually we were taught disease
treatment and not about health what
actually creates health
and so for me and to wrap the story up
being in that scenario
and seeking out help from the scenario
that's telling me that i can't get
better
finally one day as is two years it took
two years fortunately i learned the
lesson
and i realized that even though my
physicians meant well they were not
walking in my shoes
they didn't have the final say about
what was possible for me
and
i realized that you know they might be
out at dinner right now or having dinner
with their family and i'm silently
suffering
in my one bedroom apartment in ferguson
missouri just like broken down and now
i've gained all this weight i feel
absolutely terrible it's like hurling i
couldn't even recognize myself anymore
and it was in that moment when i really
hit rock bottom that i realized that
i've been outsourcing my potential in my
health to other people and even though
they might be
viable coaches or sources of of
information
it's up to me i put the food in my mouth
i'm the one who moves my body
i'm the one who has my practices my
habits and all the things that that that
manifest health and so
here's the the end of the story where it
everything changed for the better
when i had that insight and decided
and it is
it i can't stress this enough how simple
it is but it's not easy
i decided to get well
and most people never do that when
they're struggling with a health issue
it's more like wishful thinking like i i
wish this didn't happen i hope somebody
could help me i know because i was
repeating those things in my mind sure
why me why won't somebody help me
victimization being a victim having a
new role in life now you're you're this
i'm the diabetic i'm the cancer i'm i'm
this it's like no
you're you're not any of those things if
you just you know you can be something
else
these things create our identity
right and our identity the number one
driving force of the human psyche is to
stay congruent with the beliefs that we
carry about ourselves
so we will continuously do
think
believe and act in accordance with who
we believe ourselves to be and how we
believe the world to be
and so when we try to change outside of
that that's where all the discomfort
comes from
because we want to we're even though we
might not be happy with who we are we're
comfortable with who we are and we don't
realize it
and so
for me in that moment of deciding like
no come no matter what i'm going to get
better i'm going to what can i do and i
shifted the question in my mind what can
i do to get better because i've been
looking for them to tell me what to do
and they keep telling me they can't do
anything
and so
from that moment three simple quick
things and we can dive into them deeper
if you want but
number one my low-hanging fruit was
fitness and movement i'd be grown up as
an athlete and now i relented to not do
anything at all so i just went to the
school gym
i couldn't really walk well because of
this pain and so i just got on
elliptical i'm sorry i got on an
exercise bike at first and just kind of
did some pedaling which was not easy
and then you know within a couple of
weeks you know i was doing elliptical i
was walking a little bit i picked up a
couple little dumbbells doing a little
this and that
and i started to feel better
simultaneously
i also had this insight when i asked the
question what can i do to get better it
started to change my perception about
what was going on around me because
being in ferguson missouri i'm inundated
with processed food and fast food i'm
talking about i'm not exaggerating at
all within a mile and a half radius
there's papa john's domino's taco bell
arby's steak and shake krispy kremes
chinese food restaurant but not like a
nice chinese food restaurant it's like
bulletproof glass like really really
crappy virgin chinese food dairy queen
multiple mcdonald's burger king
wendy's this is this i'm just sharing
with you literally half i'm just
surrounded by lee's chicken pop pop ice
chicken liquor stores
and so i don't know what health looks
like i don't know
i didn't know that food mattered that i
get to make choose what i'm making my
tissues out of so i asked what can i do
to get better
and suddenly
people in my life
i knew this particular woman for a
couple of years at this time so i'm 22
when this happens
and i've known her since i was like 20
or maybe even 19
and she was a chiropractor
and i would just like hang out with her
i thought you know she's kind of weird
whatever but she took me within within a
couple of days of me making a decision
to get well took me to wild oats which
is
oh my god the original whole foods the
original wild oats
i went to the one in ohio and i lived in
in dublin i was like that's so funny
wild oats and you were like what's this
what is all this what is a wheatgrass
shot
right that was the first thing i noticed
like why is there grass inside
what is what's wrong with these people
but then i found some books
and they had these peer-reviewed studies
and you know i was in in college at the
time and so i was adept at research and
that kind of thing and honestly i mean
school was always just really easy for
me there was like my last couple of
years i didn't even buy any of the books
my wife knows you know i met i met her
at school at the college and i would
just like honestly go take some notes
every now and then but i wouldn't even
go to class at office come and take the
test and pass the classes um so but i
had this skill set of like identifying
what matters right
and so i started to see these studies on
like degenerative disc disease
and uh blow bone density and i'm just
like what i didn't know that this
matters for bone density silica and
sulfur-bearing amino acids and omega-3s
i didn't know omega-3s mattered what the
hell is an omega-3 and so
once i found these things out and i
started to put get these these nutrients
because a foundational question and and
this answer for everybody
is if you are experiencing damage to a
particular tissue
a simple question is what is the tissue
made of right what is it made of because
you have to supply your body with the
raw materials to build that thing
and our bodies are amazing they can do a
patchwork job on you
but once you give your body the ideal
things your body's so intelligent it
will suit it will preferentially choose
the right stuff and so i start to flood
my body initially i became a natural
pill popper to be honest like i was like
oh this nutri very expensive on a
college budget and also not sustainable
it wasn't that it's lacking an
intelligence a layer of intelligence
there with these synthetic isolated
nutrients versus the real foods that
they're found in with all these
biopotentiators and all these other
nutrients that in my nutritional science
class i was not taught about that stuff
i was taught to tell patients make sure
you get plenty of vitamin c what kind
there's multiple forms of vitamin c
there's multiple forms of vitamins don't
you just love that vitamin c is
supposedly the hot like everybody thinks
oh orange juice but it's higher in like
kiwis and strawberries and
other things like that are you know
seemingly
you know that are more healthy than
drinking a glass of orange juice
that's because of marketing you know
this you know marketing was telling us
get your drink your o.j your get your
sunny d barely is really orange juice
that i don't even know what i don't even
till this day and it's tang do you ever
remember tang i love it of course when i
was a kid
in the commercials it was i think it was
like some lips it was just like some
lips with the legs and it's just like
yeah but i mean the ingredients on there
are in pure insanity you know some of
the stuff has actually been a couple of
ingredients in tang are not no longer in
use because they've been banned
but so i what i did was i shifted to to
the to the real foods and just start to
flood my body with these nutrients
and the third thing was
if you're not sleeping well you're not
healing well yeah my biggest struggle
over those two years was sleeping at
night i was in so much pain and the
things that i was doing during the day
ended up helping me to sleep better at
night and once i could start to sleep
and i'm providing my body with these
building these very essential critical
building blocks
and the movement because i came across a
study on it was actually on racehorses
and this is a multi-billion dollar
uh entity as well
and racehorse might be worth tens of
millions of dollars if they break a leg
that can be a major thing so they did
this study and they find out how between
the horse and their sperm they're worth
a lot
right
it's a very i mean shout out to you
every guy in the world's like man i want
a stud feet
shout out to the what is it called the
the the what is the derby the triple
crown shout out to the triple crown but
you know they want to increase the bone
density of these horses so they had a
control group and then they had a a
study group where they gave the horses
basically what i was doing
supplementation increased nutrition to
increase their bone density and it did
improve their bone density but they had
another study group of horses that they
gave nutri nutrition to and walked the
horses and they had an even higher
increase in their bone density and this
speaks to what movement is really for
unfortunately we've d we've devolved
from an understanding of what movement
is about which this concept of going and
exercising which i love
is a new invention we never had that as
a
as a species throughout our evolution
because movement was just life we just
lifted heavy stuff we we moved around we
had plenty of of walking and foraging
and all these different things now
that's true like you were just a farmer
you built things or you know there was
no it wasn't like you'd purposely walk
into a box where there was like bars
hanging and things on the wall to throw
and dumbbells and yeah that's totally
true never thought about that
yeah it's it's so interesting because
and this leads into
what does this mean for us what did that
movement that our genes expect us to
move our dna
expects us to move is a part of being
human
and so what this movement is if you
think about the word exercise it's very
close to the word xor size
by the way which kind of needs to expel
things to get things out of the
environment and a big part of exercise
that we have now mountains of period
evidence on is elimination right this
quote detoxification
uh supporting mechanisms through
exercise and through movement but
another big part of exercise is
assimilation
and being able to actually absorb all
the the good stuff that you're eating if
you're changing your nutrition you're
not getting the full benefit unless
you're moving your body that's what
exercise is really about
assimilation digestion and also
elimination such a powerful supportive
force in those things so bottom line um
about
two weeks
from that day of making that decision i
was already feeling incredibly better
but it was six weeks later that i
realized that the pain i've been
experiencing every day in my life for
those two years that had me terrified it
was gone now i wanna i wanna make this
clear
i was so afraid that it would come back
i was just i was actually terrified
because it's just like what is what if i
make a wrong step i don't know what
happened i was look i was so used to
having the pain i was looking for the
pain it was
exciting neuroplasticity was
you know had happened and needs to
happen again you learned how to you
learned how to be worried about pain and
now you have to learn how to not worry
about it
exactly that is exactly right and
during that period people start to come
up to me at the university that i worked
at i mean i didn't work there yet that i
was going to school at and
teachers so professors would come up to
me
and fellow students faculty members
these just started to be like it was
like a magnetic thing they was coming up
and they were like what did you do you
look so healthy like like it was a
problem because i looked i looked like a
complete ghost are you on drugs and
you're like actually i'm off of them
so they're coming up and asking me
and then they would ask me if i can help
them and so these start to become like
the first clients that i was working
with as i was working on my degree
and i got a scan on my sp
spine done about it took it was nine
months later and i was still i was
scared i didn't need to get that
affirmation but i kind of did i want to
see for myself and i saw the last
physician
that i had worked with and he put the
mri out for me and my my two herniated
discs l4 and l5 s1 they had retracted on
their own and my degeneration
had reversed essentially and i could see
the light shining through my disc again
they look like healthy discs
whereas you know my first physician said
that the spine of an eight-year-old and
now here i was and you know at the time
he was he asked me what i did
and i told him like you know
at the time at the time i didn't have
the vocabulary and i was so
overjoyed with this experience
that and everybody out there who's who
knows about health is passionate about
health they probably have this
experience that you just start saying
all this stuff and people just don't
they're not even getting it so over
there and i'm like i'm i'm exercising
and i'm i've
do you know about you know these quote
super foods and all these different in
it he's just like okay yeah yeah but
he's like whatever you're doing keep
doing it
instead of really he's seeing the my mri
instead of him really inquiring
what did you do to get these results so
i can replicate this in other patients
that's what he said to me and i left
there he asked you he didn't ask you or
he didn't yeah he did but it was just
kind of like a formality he wasn't he
didn't really
the answer that i gave him didn't fit
the paradigm that he was expecting like
i guess he thought maybe i took some
experimental new drug i don't know but i
didn't give him the answer that he
wanted and uh this is the the cherry on
top of story from that moment you know i
i was already working with people but i
you know i graduated got my degree i was
already a strength conditioning coach
uh at that point i really went intense
in that i shifted all my coursework back
to biology and kinesiology nutritional
science
opened my clinical practice as a
nutritionist worked with thousands of
people in a one-on-one context and also
just small workshops and things like
that and saw you know i've got people
coming in
400 their blood sugar is like 400 you
know they're on metformin insulin people
on you know the centerpro for heart
disease and hypertension and you know
folks who are diagnosed with cancer and
all these different things and seeing so
much success a lot of those stories
where people who they they've been told
the same thing there's nothing you can
do about this and the number one thing
that i would do
and so for example we had about an 80
uh success rate with folks coming in who
were diagnosed with type 2 diabetes to
normalize their blood sugar without
medication working with their along with
their physician sure oftentimes within a
matter of weeks you know and what the
number one thing that we did i literally
would just take the time i would a lot
the time
to sit down with them i had this this
board you know this white board and i
would walk them through kind of reverse
engineer the disease like okay so
you're diagnosed with diabetes here's
how it works
here's your pancreas these are alpha
cells these are beta cells and i would
take them through the process
and i could see the light
come on in their eyes like they're
literally like
waking up in that moment like i had no
idea what was happening in my own body
again you showed them the science it's
one thing to say things another thing to
show somebody how it works and then they
go oh exactly exactly so an aha moment
in in those in that experience and
seeing that day after day after day
eventually i was like i need to write
this down or i need to you know get this
out to other people because you have a
book called sleep smarter which you said
that's one of the three things you have
a book called eat smarter which is
another one of the things you said but
there's no exercise smarter where's that
book
well
dot dot
who listen so we've got we've got the
sparta series you know there's a lot
more to come from that but sleep smarter
which again i'm a nutritionist i didn't
my intention wasn't to become a sleep
wellness expert
but i just taught a uh a class at nyu
that came on as a guest lecturer for the
neuroscience department and teaching
them about sleep and you know
speaking at google you i mean you name
it all these different medical
conventions and really
folks might not know this because they
might be introduced to me for the first
time but sleep smarter came out as the
first sleep wellness book to actually
become an international bestseller
and you know it's sold i mean
it's it's insane it's like translated a
couple you can see over there it's been
translated in like 20 different
countries i think now and all these are
all separate foreign publications
love
and it created thank you so much but it
created the industry because i had to
fight for it
because publishers was like you know
what you could do really well with a
nutrition book or you know this is hot
right now that sleep hadn't ever it had
never done well and people now it's like
some of the things that i put into
culture are part of the lexicon you know
i just did a talk
for tom brady's uh tb12
company and they have like sleep
wellness experts and all these things
sleep wellness coaches and that domain
might not have existed had i not stood
up for and i was just like listen i've
got people coming in who
we're doing all we've got their
nutrition dialed in their movement
practices
but if they're not sleeping their blood
sugar is still deranged as soon as we
employ these clinically proven tactics
to improve their sleep quality
the blood sugar finally normalizes the
weight finally comes off the
hypertension finally
dissolves their memory you know we can
talk about this as well you know memory
processing takes place during rem sleep
for example and so now their cognition
is improving and all these different
wonderful things i'm just like this is
the missing piece this isn't this is a
gap
in the education
and so but also sleep can seem like
which is crazy now because you know you
can make it sexy which that wasn't
really my goal to make it attractive but
it can be a boring topic it's the most
like overlooked thing in our culture as
far as wellness it's just like we we
have this idea that we have to do
something to get something so you know
we got to keep grinding got to work
harder we got to count our calories all
these different things
but sleep is something where you do
nothing and you get everything
you know and it controls your nutrition
and your assimilation and your you know
your your hunger and satiety
and it controls
your even if your performance to a
massive degree you know so i had all
that data but the thing that set it
apart was the practicality so number one
making sleep attractive but number two
there's 21 clinically proven strategies
clinically proven all clinically proven
to improve your sleep quality and these
are most of them are things you don't
have to turn your world upside down to
get the benefits because i knew in my
practice that people want change they
want to get these results
but they often don't want to change that
much that's the thing easy
they want change but they don't want to
change that much what i love about
nutrition
and wellness overall
and i've been down my own wellness
journey this year i've been a lab rat
i've had a needle in my arm drawing
blood many many times this year i've
done all the tests i've done all the
stool and urine and saliva and blood and
i've like learned so much about it um
and i'm a lot of the things that you're
saying are just hitting home because
uh you know i'm generally a pretty well
person and i operate at a high level but
a couple things started happening and i
was like i don't understand this and so
you know the body was giving me warning
signs but what's so fascinating about
learning about all of this in the last
six months for me
is that
everything overlaps
and there's not you know when i got test
results from things and it'd be like
okay well for this you need these these
are the things to help it and then
there'd be other other areas that needed
um certain supplementation for a while
for gut protocols and things like that
and they'd overlap and so when you talk
about sleep
i think about i think to myself
that you can do things to help you sleep
but it's also a symptom too you know
this it can be a symptom of something
else so maybe it's not actually the
sleep that's the problem but of course
you need sleep to heal and to uh
reach more of a state of homeostasis and
give your body a chance to you know you
know all the science behind that but
sleep is a critical
of importance for for well-being so i
love how it overlaps so
i i i'm gonna rattle off a few things
that i was thinking about asking you
about and maybe it's better if you just
tell me
uh at the end of rattling off some of
these things we can hit on them because
look we could go on and on and on we
could do it we could have our a whole
podcast together that all we do is hit
on one new topic and you know go off on
it because there's so much information
but you know the things that i was
thinking about were and some of these
i'm curious personally because i have i
i need my own wellness but i know that
they're big buckets in general so
everything from uh from hormones so the
uh the endocrine endocrine system to
toxins and how that affects the body um
mitochondria and the role of that
sleep of course and um let's see other
things i was going to ask about
epi caloric control and the quality of
the
uh the quality of the ingredients that
we're getting in the rolls that they
play on a on a more macro level than
just the micro of calories because you
know i always think too that you know
similar to sleep that
um
you know the question everybody wants
answered is right like how do i lose
weight
but generally when you become more
healthy you just do
right so when you start to fix the
inside the outside reflects it
um
so
stress
mindset uh our thoughts our environment
um so what of those things that i just
mentioned
stand out and make you want to say
this is what people need to know
yeah the first thing we start right
where you started which is hormones
and and the first is understanding so
what are hormones right so these this is
another word that's in our lexicon that
folks don't really have an adequate
education on our empowerment about
hormones are super powerful and
fascinating these are essentially
these chemical messengers that
send data that are able to communicate
data from one cell to another
so they're kind of like these metabolic
dms
right and they're sending data from one
place to another from all all various
cells in your body are picking up on
this data
and the question should be what if the
data that's getting sent is damaged
somehow or what if it goes to spam right
what if you have insulin resistance or
leptin resistance
where that
metabolic messenger leptin or insulin is
no longer to deliver its message
adequately right what happens then so
this is how important and powerful our
hormones are it's really
i mean of everything if we're trying to
identify like what is a foundational
thing that we can kind of manipulate in
a positive or negative way
is our hormones and also our
neurotransmitters when it comes to the
nervous system for example they're kind
of operating in the same medium of
communication so we got
neurotransmitters neuropeptides hormones
now with that said the thing that jumped
out for me the most of those things that
you mentioned is epic caloric control
and so epicolor control so me being a
nutritionist when i was in my
nutritional science class in college
the very first day of school the
professor comes in and also again
sidebar he was not in a good state of
health you could tell
um but i you just put that you push that
to the back of your mind like you just
oh he's a professor he's smart guy he
was he was brilliant
but when you take a very smart person
and you teach them the wrong thing they
become world-class at doing the wrong
thing and teaching the wrong thing
and so he was teaching the the
cookie-cutter paradigm of this food
pyramid and telling us to make sure you
get in you know and instruct people you
work with to get seven to 11 servings of
whole grains every day
and the list goes on and on but the
first thing that he said they won is
that if you can control calories
you can control weight if you if you can
control calories you can control your
health
and so it's this paradigm the first
thing for me and i take people through
this adventure in eat smarter on where
the calorie came from like where did the
concept of the calorie come from and it
actually originated was not it was in
physics and engineering had nothing to
do with nutrition
but you know i take people through that
that adventure but eventually we get to
this place of like where did it become
so popularizing our culture as this
powerful it's the dominant metric to
manage and it was thanks to a woman
named dr lulu hunt peters in the earlier
part like the 1900s and she had a
massive bestseller
that
essentially was
regarding the key key to the calories
right and she's really creating this
uh in a sense this this very powerful
uh paradigm that if you can control
calories you can control your weight
and sidebar for her as well she
struggled with her weight
her entire life it did not fix her
problem by the way but here's the thing
so it came into culture
and it was telling people specifically
she's more so speaking to women
that
we will no longer eat food you will now
eat calories of food
and
from that you will no longer eat a slice
of bread you'll eat 100 calories of
bread you'll no longer eat a slice of
pie you'll eat 350 calories of pie
so we're changing this very complex the
human body is the most dynamic
entity in the known universe you know
michio kaku
theoretical physicist said the human
brain is the most complicated object in
the known universe and we're now taking
this very powerful it's not a calculator
with calories it's really a glorified
laboratory and chemistry
set in environment and now we're just
saying if you could do this one thing
you're going to get these results so
um
that's where the next idea
as an example of something i found
fascinating one of the tests i've done
um was i used a continuous blood glucose
monitor for a month and
whenever i would be stressed and like
had a conversation that was heated or
something like that uh my blood sugar
would go up i didn't even need anything
yeah it's like an example of how
complicated this system is that there's
like a million overlapping things in the
body that go oh no you can't just do
this one thing and have the other things
not matter
so the fact that they're trying to use
one metric which i've even thought about
the metric of a calorie like how do you
calculate it right like i know that
there's i think there's some sort of
like bunsen burners program that you put
things through
and get some kind of metric right but
i'm like
that's not what they're doing what a
calorie was
you're right that's but they're not
doing that today so it's a bomb
calorimeter was what was used initially
to
disseminate how many calories are in a
particular substance but it was never
accurate it would never was because it
didn't
account for indigestible parts of food
for example basically to put into
um you know a a container that goes
inside of another container it's filled
with water then use electrical energy to
burn the food incinerated and then you
like the
that's what you use to measure how many
calories are there
it's so you're this is the thing you're
not a bomb colorimeter you're a human
being by the way number one number two
this is not what's used in
in counting how many calories are in
your food which is based on the at water
system which again we could take time
and break down all what that means
basically they're just doing math food
manufacturers are just doing math and
putting it on the food label
so but still it can give us it's not to
say that a calorie can be a viable
tool that we utilize but we've made the
calorie the king of nutrition and look
where it's got us there are going to be
some people that like well i've used
calorie management and it's helped me
that's great
it's going to help people but when we
make that the dominant thing and ignore
what i'm about to share that's where
things go dramatically wrong and and our
society's results are sharing that with
252 million citizens in the united
states right now are overweight or obese
and there's like
320 million in the country
it's insane it's like beyond epidemic
proportions and so here's what's going
on so here's a couple of things these
are epicolor controllers these are
things that actually control what
calories do in your body
all right so and i'm and i'm so grateful
to be able to say this but my and to be
able to talk with you about it because
you really understand but bruce lipton
was my inspiration for creating the term
epicaloric
and so these are controllers
above caloric control these are what
these are things that control what
calories do in your body so one of them
is your brain and neural inflammation
your brain controls what calories do in
your body have a massive influence
on your digestion and assimilation and
so a recent report this was published in
the annals of the new york academy of
sciences
and it reported that hypothalamic
inflammation so this is inflammation
regarding the hypothalamus that is a
integrator of your endocrine system your
hormones and your nervous system your
neurotransmitters
and so they said that this inflammation
in the hypothalamus which is
probably the biggest epidemic happening
right now that people don't know about
we'll talk about why
is a double-edged sword in nutritional
diseases the study authors reported that
systemic inflammation from things like
metabolic dysfunction right so
diabetes for example
that issue in it of itself
metabolic dysfunction and excessive body
fat leads to brain inflammation
all right so carrying body fat creates
inflammation in the hypothalamus
and inflammation of the hypothalamus
creates excessive body fat
and metabolic dysfunction
so we get into this vicious circle
and essentially
your brain you have the your vagus nerve
that's connecting the gut and the brain
for example and i talk about this in
each smart as well but essentially
there's this constant
light speed feedback loop
with your gut in that which is also
called the enteric nervous system or the
second brain because it's there's like a
massive neural tissue
in the gut itself there's more we have
more neurotransmitters in our gut than
we do in our brain isn't that is that am
i reporting um is that good information
or bad information
the brain the brain has the most okay
but the second most is is found in that
yes and even the heart as well has its
own that we call it the heart brain has
there's a significant amount of
of neural tissue very similar to what's
in the brain in our heart as well but
that's a whole other thing so here's
here's what happens so there's this
constant feedback loop taking place
and based on the assessment
between your brain and your gut on how
much energy you have stored in your body
what nutrients you need
your brain can actually signal your gut
to shut down the absorption of calories
from your food or increase the
absorption of calories from your food
all right based on your overall
metabolic assessment of what you have
in your body so
theoretically just say you eat 100
calories of something your with the
information your brain your gut has it
can tell your body like oh we only need
50 of those calories
and this is not accounted for in
conventional caloric management
equations that your brain and your gut
can literally determine and dysfunction
with them can determine
how many calories you're absorbing are
not absorbing and this goes back to
hormones with again if there's
resistance or there's leptin resistance
or insulin resistance and your body
thinks that you're starving even though
you've got a tremendous amount of fat
stored in your body
right
this is where we can have an increased
assimilation of calories from the same
food that another person might eat and
they're not even absorbing as much
so that's number one and i'll just share
it like two two more but i go through
and talk about really there's seven of
these epicolor controllers that we
identify but one of them is neural
inflammation another one how do we
reduce it then can you give us a little
like uh some more
nice just like for each one of the words
what we can do because it's one thing to
know it's another thing to have a call
to action
yes i like you're amazing all right so
this is so this was done by researchers
at auburn university all right and i'm
this is not an advocation for what they
shared but the data exists and it's
fascinating
so what they discovered was that
oleokanthal rich extra virgin olive oil
is able to actually repair
the blood-brain barrier
and to decrease brain inflammation
all right and it just it is what it is
because of the the blood-brain barrier
is this protective system for the brain
the brain has its own specific diet we
call it neural nutrition a lot of stuff
isn't able to enter the brain but as the
blood-brain barrier is broken down
through
uh toxicants
abnormal things that we bring in through
our nutrition
stress can break down that blood-brain
barrier
and so to help to regenerate and to heal
it
funny enough and again i wasn't the
biggest fan of olive oil but i was like
this is that's incredible to be able to
have that kind of effect on the brain
like that's remarkable so what the
researchers found was two to three
tablespoons a day
uh appears to be very therapeutic
in healing and assisting in reducing
neural inflammation and that's one i
mean i could again we could spend the
whole time no that's great just
something that people can do
i mean doesn't the brain the brain feeds
off of fat right isn't that one of the
one of the things that makes the brain
operate um
so much human brain it is it is fat it's
primarily fat if we're talking about the
dry weight the brain is primarily water
by the way so we're talking about
somewhere in the ballpark of 80 water
which is another solution if we're
talking about inflammation or fire
water
would be an important attribute here but
most people in our society are walking
around walking around with dehydrated
brains
so
taking water out of the equation the
brain is primarily fat but we got to go
deeper than that what kind of fat
because not all fats are able to
actually enter the brain and pass the
blood-brain barrier so cholesterol is
one of the primary fats the brain is
made of
we've got sphingolipids another one as
well phospholipids
we've got sphingomyelin you know i can
go on and on and break these down and
there's certain foods that provide the
building blocks
that are able to actually cross the
blood vessels eat smarter is the
information in each smarter your book
most of it is but even in the chapter we
talk about cognitive health and brain
health i couldn't put everything that i
know in the data in there but also i do
talk about it on my show quite a bit
like i got mastered yeah oh yeah yeah
the facts of the brain and sciences and
things are always emerging and that's
the beautiful thing about wellness is we
just keep learning so okay olive oil
love it a couple of tablespoons a day
will help with the blood brain
barrier and help you with uh with
inflammation love it yes so another one
of these epicolor controllers
and this is one of the biggest takeaways
from today because it's affirming
something that we might say
or a belief that we might carry about
nutrition but now we have solid science
to affirm this factor and another
controller of what calories actually do
in your body is the type of food itself
so people might say all calories are not
created equal now we have the data so
this study was published in food and
nutrition research
and they set out to find
whether or not there's a difference in
calories absorbed assimilated in
metabolic function
from eating a meal of whole foods versus
a meal of processed foods
right and so in the experiment what they
used was a whole food sandwich which
again i'm not this is not about whether
or not this is
the best source of whole foods but this
is what they did it was a whole food
sandwich which included a whole grain
bread and cheddar cheese and then they
had test subjects to consume a processed
food sandwich which was made of white
bread and cheese product with cheese
product that's what craft is by the way
we grew up on
yes so it's not you can't legally even
call it cheese you know it's clap craft
singles because it's not enough amazing
what our body will be it's amazing the
resilience that our body has that we can
feed it you know
fruit roll-ups and gushers and
you know uh
craft singles golden grahams golden yeah
golden fit goldfish and pockets we still
grow to be these you know we still keep
getting taller and we still keep getting
smarter it's really amazing the human
body is incredibly resilient to say the
least you know but just imagine what
happens when we really get on the good
stuff and what our genes are expecting
and so here's what happened so they gave
folks you know to see again what how do
calories react in their bodies when
eating a meal of whole foods or a meal
of processed foods
and so what they discovered was that
when the test participants
ate the processed food sandwich they had
a 50
reduction in calorie burn after
consuming that sandwich versus when they
ate the meal of whole foods
okay so the processed version of these
foods which were very abnormal not
really anything that the human body can
even recognize as food it created what i
call essentially these hormonal clogs
that created dysfunction and disruption
in the body's processing of those
calories making the body more stingy and
hanging on to that caloric energy and
not in a sense not really knowing what
to do with it
you know versus when they ate the more
whole food version of it it was more
efficient in the expenditure of the of
those calories so
truly the type of food matters so when
we have these different diets again they
can be effective but if it's a point
system diet for example and it's not
paying attention to the quality of the
food we're shooting ourselves in the
foot and you've got to look at the even
the people who are promoting them you
know oftentimes they continue to
struggle with their weight and we're
just like oh whatever
whatever you know it's it's it's my
fault it's my fault i'm not making the
point system work for me it's my fault
that i'm not counting the calories
adequately enough like i gotta i gotta
cut them more i gotta cut them harder
i've had patients come in who are eating
under a thousand calories a day and
their weight will not so hard to do
we're working with you know their weight
loss
doctor and they come in they're they're
just metabolically broken and they've
created a state of learned helplessness
where they think it's their fault like
they're just not trying hard enough yeah
and not under not getting this education
on here's how your body and these
your hormones and your organs and your
fat loss related processes here's how it
all works let's get you well let's heal
these systems or someone that just
thinks to myself or thinks of themselves
kind of like with your health journey
about oh well i just have this disease i
just have this condition this is the way
i am somebody might just think oh this
is the way i am i'm just heavy or this
is the way i am i just this
it's like they accept it as their
reality too instead of going now you
know what my intuition says i'm trying
and i'm not getting anywhere
maybe i need to look somewhere else
yeah yeah and
there's so much more you know i i
remember
one of the running kind of it became
funny after a while
is that people would come in and they
were like i've tried everything
i've tried everything
and when i actually get them to tell me
the things they've tried it'll be like
three things you know it's just like but
we really feel that way we're three
weeks each
but we really feel that way you know we
really work hard and try to make things
happen but then we end up blaming
ourselves and not the system yeah that
has given us this paradigm that this is
the way to get there which again just
look at the system look at the the
results itself i know the people i've
worked with them firsthand
they're not not trying hard or they're
not not disciplined
it's that we're all so incredibly unique
which leads me to i'll just share one
more
yeah i'd love it keep going it's this is
such amazing information
um did we get to a call to action for
that last one so he eating real food
right yep there you go real food i
always think the the logic i try and use
is what how close can i get for it to be
made by the sun
right or like maybe the next byproduct
from the sun
so plants that come i mean i'm such an
advocate of a garden now i live in
arizona so i don't have one right now
but um i desperately would like one i
had one when i lived in north carolina
and i loved it um but you know thinking
like that like can i grow something
where can i can i go to a farmer's
market how can i get something that
literally gets picked and eaten right
away and you know the next by-product
would be you know animal animal protein
let's say is a byproduct of the sun
right they eat the grass that then
becomes them and so
but the closer we can eat to things that
were made by the sun
is trying what i try and think of i also
try and eat something that's alive at
each meal so maybe i'll cook things and
i tend to enjoy and it sits well with me
to eat things cooked but then i'll just
go oh i'll throw some micro greens on
that that's that's alive
um so you know those are some things
that i do i love it that's that's great
advice you know it's very simple again
what have we evolved doing as a species
what is the things we've been doing the
longest
which is reading eating real food
and you know only it's only recent like
literally we're talking about a few
decades
and the extent to the extent of even
a couple of centuries if we're talking
about highly refined processing of sugar
and things like that
you know
in the in the
gigantic evolution of of humanity we're
talking about
a book that might be
we'll just say
a million pages we're talking about like
a sentence yeah on one of the pages on
how long we've been eating foods that we
can't even recognize where they come
from anymore i don't have no idea where
the hell if you just seen a hot pocket
you just came across it if it was like
you're out foraging is like you see the
hot pocket you're like you have no
identification of where that hot pocket
came from except jim gaffigan maybe oh
geez
well i mean
you know it's uh it's it's crazy that
something that just gets pulled right
out of the ground you know unfortunately
has a certain price tag on it and then
something that requires an entire
building and a huge system in order to
put it through a process um is you know
a dollar oh nine for something that is
much more highly processed it's like you
know it it's also not an encouraging
format either for people because ever
you know most people have to you know be
careful how much they spend and but at
the end of the day i feel like there was
some stat i heard or read a long time
ago that was
that uh of course health being an
investment and that the average person
spends 300 000 at the end of their life
trying to save it and so if you just
took that 300 000 and just spent it your
whole life and and then allowed yourself
the freedom to be able to
live um vigorously and vibrantly and be
able to do whatever you want and feel
and look better
it's a different story yeah it sounds so
good and so accessible and so if people
are wondering for example why is it that
you know an avocado might cost three
dollars and you can get three
cheeseburgers for three dollars like how
is that possible it really has a lot to
do with
government subsidies and i break this
down and eat smarter as well because
it's such an important part of the
conversation
because from 1995 to 2010 alone the u.s
government handed out almost 200 billion
dollars in agricultural subsidies to
companies who their products largely
make processed food and fast food
right and so
this is why you can go
and let me let me give you an example
because i want to find out okay
is this actually affecting our health do
we have data on this
and a study has published in one of our
most prestigious journals the journal of
the american medical association jama
they tracked the intake
of the subsidized foods from the
government right so the the highest
intake
of government subsidized foods again
coming primarily through the fast food
window processed foods they found that
people who have the highest intake of
government subsidized foods have almost
a 40 greater incidence of being obese
all right we've got the data it's not a
joke it's not like well this sounds like
it might be true or like an
observational
thing you know like we've got some
pretty sounds now loop that back around
to the thing that we first led off with
which is you know the highest percentage
of fatalities with covet is obese people
i mean let's just keep looping it right
it's like
just you know
take care like how do we do it you just
said it this is not being addressed
because it was never meant to be
addressed we're talking about our
government unfortunately funding
yeah disease in our culture
and not taking responsibility for it but
the thing is at the end of the day we
have to take responsibility it's right
you started the show talking about
sovereignty and personal responsibility
truly it is up to us and then we can
expand from there and impact our
families and our communities but we
gotta we've got to mind ourselves first
and truly we live in we
the united states is literally the
sickest nation in the history of
humanity but i'm talking about chronic
self-inflicted lifestyle related
diseases
i mentioned already we have 242 million
citizens who are overweight or obese
prior to pandemic by the way those
numbers have
jumped up
since then we've got 115 million
americans who are regularly sleep
deprived we've got 130 million americans
who are diabetic or pre-diabetic we've
got 60 percent of our population has
some degree of heart disease already
we've got about
25 to 50 million americans have
autoimmune condition which they've just
all this has come out of nowhere all
these skyrocketing rates i can go on and
on and on with with the statistics but
we're not doing anything about it
everything keeps getting worse we keep
having more drugs we keep having more
treatments 70 of our citizens are
already on pharmaceutical drugs but it's
not working we're not removing the cause
which the journal of the american
medical association is 2018
big meta-analysis they said that poor
diet is the number one cause of our
epidemic chronic diseases heart disease
diabetes obesity
we know this already but the thing is
truly who cares we have to care and we
can change this stuff
so um if i could share that last one in
the um these epicolor controllers which
is really
where
a lot of the science is at today you
know i'm already on to some other stuff
beyond this
but this is something because you know
10 years ago
in my practice like like you mentioned i
send people out to get a stool sample
and like let's see what's going on with
their with their microbes which is the
most humbling experience i've ever had
to literally
poop in my hand into a like uh nacho
basket a hot dog basket
honestly it's just the most humbling
thing i've ever done
so yeah it is it is what it is all for
health and wellness though right all for
all in the name of science you know i'm
gonna poop into this nacho basket
so
uh the the the frontier that people are
on right now is
this fascination with the microbiome and
rightfully so that was the one thing i
forgot to mention because i know that
that's such a i mean obviously with the
neurotransmitters and you know second
brain
microbiome and gut health of course is
something to think about so i'm glad
you're hitting on it thanks for reading
my mind
of course of course and so that's it's
you know it's greg braden you know he's
taught us how to do that so here's the
thing so with the microphone i think he
is i'm not sure he might be an alien
here on earth maybe there's possible
it's possible yeah so
the with the microbiome this is an
epicolor controller as well
your gut bacteria which we have
upwards of like 40 trillion plus
gut bacteria so
specifically bacteria with the human
microbiome
it isn't just bacteria i just want to
preface by saying this we also have
i mean i'm talking trillions like 400
trillion virus particles that live in
and on our bodies all right
we've got a plethora of fungi and
archaea
like these ancient microbes like it's
crazy
we're we're far we're not as human as we
think we're it's we're symbiosis we are
a walking
rain forest in a sense and so the
microbiome if we're talking about we're
talking specifically about bacteria
which are gut bacteria
we know that we have these quote
friendly flora very friendly bacteria
these probiotics and we also have
um kind of what we would term to be
um
pathogenic or opportunistic bacteria
which even within that we all have an
array of all of them but it's about the
balance because even what we refer to as
these kind of opportunistic bacteria
we have to
in a normal healthy human microbiome
when being able to study people you know
hunter-gatherer tribes who have healthy
microbiomes
if we isolated this particular bacteria
we call opportunistic and just said it's
bad we miss out on the fact that oh this
is actually doing this for us
this is helping to create b12 or this is
helping to do fill in the blank
creating helping doing something in us
for us but when it becomes a dominant
strain when it's not kept in check and
imbalance that's when it can become
pathogenic or hurtful so we have to keep
this all in context so when i say like
friendly bacteria or opportunistic
still you have to have that caveat that
everything plays a part and so here's
the point with epic caloric control so
one of the studies that i outlined uh in
more in depth i'll just give the bullet
points here
in each smarter but it's really
fascinating to understand
is the researchers
we've basically identified that there's
a certain microbiome makeup that's
associated with obesity and insulin
resistance
and
excessive body fat based on your
microbiome so that's what i was going to
say is like i could have
a patient send out for a stool sample
and i can get their report back and i
can know with a very very high accuracy
whether or not they're obese without
ever seeing them a day in my life
just based on their microbiome makeup
and so this is what the researchers uh
discovered and this was published in one
of our most prestigious
medical journals on the subject matter
and what they discovered was that this
shift can happen so what here's here
i'll give a summation i'm trying to hold
back on giving the whole thing because
that with the time but i'm good i got to
give it i got to give it to you so what
they did was
they took mice and i know we're not mice
we're not mickey mouse i'm going to come
back to us
but they took mice and they took
fecal samples from humans
and they implanted the the fecal samples
into into lean mice so they took samples
from
humans who had a gut microbiome
associated with obesity and implanted
that into lean mice and they took
samples from a human sample that has a
gut microbiome associated with leanness
and implanted that into lean mice those
mice
stayed lean they were seen that received
the quote lean bacteria the mice who
received the quote fat bacteria these
mice even though they're on the exact
same diet as the other mice nothing else
changed these mice became insulin
resistant their body fat went up and
they became obese
simply by changing their bacteria
and so this was paralleled in now in
human studies
as well and seeing the same phenomenon
and one of the best examples is
uh i cited a study done on identical
twins all right you can't get any better
comparison
and this was from my hometown so st
louis university and the researchers
took this large database and they looked
at the microbiome makeup of twins and
they found that when one of the twins
has a higher ratio
of basically they brought it down to
these firm acutes and and bacterial
deities and from it having a higher rate
uh ratio of firmicutes was more
affirmative towards being obese
and so they found when the one twin had
a high ratio of quote fat bacteria even
though they're in the same environment
doing the same thing eating the same
food one twin had a greater much greater
propensity towards becoming overweight
or obese than their identical twins okay
well what is that that's that's a lot of
that's some smart jargon but what is
that how do we fix that how do we make
sure that how do we
how do we not have the bad or the fat
building bacteria how do we change our
change our gut gut flora so that we
are
the lean mice
yes yes
shout out to mickey and minnie uh so
this i'm gonna give you two two things
number one this was a recent study this
was published in the international
journal of obesity
so again one of the most prestigious
journals on the subject matter
and it revealed that a higher diversity
of gut bacteria is directly correlated
with wet with less weight gain and
improved energy metabolism independent
of calorie intake and other factors okay
epicoloric
all right
and so going on from that taking a pivot
researchers uncovered that having a
higher diversity of foods that you eat
increases the diversity of your gut
bacteria
all right which only makes sense because
different bacteria prefer
different foods and so this is where we
have to be careful about elimination
diets which can be very helpful by the
way
because certain bacteria in order for
them to stay
in your metabolic home they have to have
their preferred food source
but a key here is the diversity
and so if you think about even if we
were for eating healthy we can get on
that
food meal prep gone awry but we're
eating the same stuff over and over
again
and diversity is one of the biggest keys
because truly if we're not giving the
bacteria to those so those are called
prebiotics
so prebiotic sources and i want to make
this point clear
every single real food
is a form of prebiotic every single one
we can so i shouldn't have taken my
prebiotic powder this morning
with my glutathione or whatever it is
the powder that tastes like chalk
so we can ice i was just going to say
that we can isolate and say hey this is
a prebiotic here this is a great
prebiotic food jerusalem artichoke
onions whatever the case might be that's
what happens when you go to dr google
fermented foods and things like that i
mean like people i think are kind of
aware of what a prebiotic is but the
fact that it's in everything is great to
know
and why is it in everything why is it
how do why is why don't we know that why
is it like oh eat prebiotic foods like
you know eat you know kraut and yogurts
and
um artichokes and certain other things
that that help with that why is it that
we don't know that
so here's the step so we have prebiotics
that feed the probiotics
that then create postbiotics
okay
so postbiotics are the things that our
bacteria make in us for us
all right so like short chain fatty
acids for example that help to maintain
the integrity of our gut lining that
even play a role now we're looking at
how these scapus produced by our
bacteria affect our brain right so
prebiotics feed the probiotics that then
make postbiotics so that's the steps why
don't we know about this
when i worked at the university
this light bulb came on and i because i
was working at university i got to meet
people from all over the world you know
from nigeria from india from iran from
france the list goes on and on and i
would ask them what kind of fermented
food did their culture eat
and a lot of times it would be like
something they had to dig up from their
memory
every time i never met one person in
this internet especially if they're
coming from that country
to the university who didn't have a
cultured food in their culture
right
and it's just something that humans have
always done we've always had as a part
of our evolution but today again it's
just been you know it's this is
processed food
hungry man dinner paradigm and then like
you know people go buy yogurt and you
know they end up buying something that's
probably a lot less like yogurt and a
lot more like sugar right gogurt it's
gogurt now you know if yogurt gogurt can
sit on i just walked by it the other day
could sit on the shelves in the middle
of the grocery store without
refrigeration
it should tell you that it might not
really be
real
in addition to the diversity of foods
and as i mentioned
every real food on planet earth
functions as a prebiotic for some
particular bacteria strain we we know so
little about nutrition right now we act
like we know everything but this is
taking a meta perspective and saying hey
truly
every one of these foods that humans
have subsisted on for
countless you know eons
functions as a prebiotic in some form or
fashion
now here's the last part
if we're talking about probiotics
themselves and accessing them directly
from foods
we've got to realize that whenever you
eat a real food
you're eating that foods microbiome
okay so if you're eating a blueberry
you're eating that blueberries
microbiome
and taking that on if you eat an avocado
you're taking that avocados microbiome
and taking that on our definition of
probiotics is very limited
so you know but that the fermented foods
can be like a powerhouse in that domain
because we've got a plethora like so
we've got sauerkraut we've got kimchi
we've got yogurts we got kefirs we've
got if you look at you know certain
cultures in in asia for example and
you know them fermenting soy for for
thousands of years and then now there's
such a debate about the quality of soy
like is that a health food they weren't
eating soy dogs and soy ice cream and
soy sandwich slices and tofurkey we
gotta understand that it's a very
different animal and also we could get
into the the genetically modified
organisms all that stuff these are all
new inventions but them fermenting soy
that they've grown themselves you can
see that that was a viable
source of probiotics but not for
everybody this is the key and really my
message
and trying to
really work in to push this in the
culture like with each with sleep
smarter it became a cultural phenomenon
and most folks they might not even know
that this stuff came from me and the
language and how i know this is that the
language people use like these were
literally bars that i wrote these are
sentences that i wrote that i created
and i could hear you know this
particular health expert saying this or
this physician saying that it's like i i
wrote that you know it's beautiful and
that's letting go
of the idea because i think and i just
want to share this for everybody
listening to
we need you right now we need you to be
in your power to share your voice
but sometimes we get scared to share
because of negative what we deem to be
like negative pushback or somebody might
take my ideas
it's 2021 it's the internet yes people
are gonna take your ideas but they
cannot replace you they can never be you
you are a unique phenomenon and this
goes back to everything we're talking
about with nutrition today
every single person on planet earth
you that you right now listening to this
there has never been a person on planet
earth that has a metabolism just like
yours or a microbiome just like yours or
brain just like yours never in the
history of humanity you are completely
unique you have a unique metabolic
fingerprint and there will never be
anyone like you
in the future ever
ever this is a unique opportunity and
here's the biggest part even yourself
tomorrow even yourself next week is not
going to be like you are now
you are a constantly evolving health is
very
fluid and dynamic but we tend to see it
as like i got this thing this is working
for me
and when that thing stops working we
beat ourselves up and not understand we
are evolving and changing
and we can get into an adventure
paradigm of constantly exploring and
adapting as things go
i think that's a perfect way to close
the loop back to
well said thank you so much for all that
information i mean there's i'm gonna go
drink some olive oil right now but um
it's such a good way to close the loop
back into the sovereignty of our
decisions and ourselves and how we show
up and what we do with our life because
no one is us so stop using cookie cutter
basics like a calorie or like do this do
that it's you're unique so trust your
instincts and trust that there might be
something going on beyond what um but
what a one-dimensional sort of doctor or
someone says to you about what to do
because you are your thoughts so if you
think that you should be feeling better
you should
i absolutely agree thank you so much i
mean
this
we have such opportunity right now you
know that's how i see it i know that
things are looking so fluxed up i said
flux they're so fluxed up but when
things are
in such a
appearance of chaos they're actually
easier to change than when they're very
fixed and solid and
you know and dogmatic and so but we have
to take advantage of it we
we're acting like unfortunately things
were going well and they were not going
well you know we're just like
accelerating the gas right towards
a bridge that has a giant hole in it you
know and this isn't like fast and
furious this is not like
a movie like literally we can
crash and burn we we're getting
treatments that appear to like be a
bridge from here to where we want to be
but we keep seeing again and again and
again that the bridge is not complete
it's not getting us there so we need to
change things and you know moments like
this
and amazing people like you you know
sharing your voice and creating entities
and platforms like this to have these
conversations truly this is how things
are going to change thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it if you like
what you heard today and you want to
hear more please click on the subscribe
button